There are 50 slots on the training tab
and when I last checked,
22 of them were taken up by either a
movie trailer,
TV,
late night host,
big brand or TV show.
This is ridiculous when you account for
the fact that youtube only has three
main tabs to exploit their entire site
and in one of them about half the
options or TV related,
which means their main product isn't
even on Youtube.
It's just an advertisement to go watch
their show or movie.
So in other words,
the trending tab has become a glorified
TV guide.
This problem isn't new.
Trending has been frustrating you tubers
since 2015 you see,
it all started when youtube released a
cryptic statement about what kind of
videos would be featured.
Some trends are predictable,
like a new song from a popular artist or
a new movie trailer.
Others are surprising like a viral
video.
We aim to surface videos that a wide
range of viewers will find interesting
and novel.
Now this guy,
people excited because it seemed like a
great way to feature new viral creators,
but that's not really what happened in
the end.
It's led to a stagnant,
predictable system where every day it
seems like a Mashup of John Oliver meets
buzzfeed glue dominated by videos that
have lots of marketing resources behind
them,
whether that be business insider,
the NFL,
snl,
what the hell?
Oh wait,
that's Casey Neistat on trending again.
But he sponsored by CNN so it's okay.
And why is this happening?
Is there a conspiracy where youtube
trying to promote big budget movies or
TV shows?
I don't think so,
but whenever you rely on an algorithm to
sort things,
people are going to find a way to
exploit an optimize for that algorithm.
When Youtube started the training tab,
they knew they didn't want already big
youtubers dominating the space everyday
with their videos to consistently got
millions of views and that makes sense.
PD Pie on training everyday would get
super old,
but how do you find viral videos when
you can't use view count as an indicator
of our rally?
Well,
youtube solution was to base who gets on
the training tab on a variety of
factors.
How vast is the video growing where the
view is coming from geographically,
but most of all,
where's the traffic being driven from?
This last factor is really important
because it explains how the Time Warner
Tab came to be because if your main way
to push content is through youtube,
you're not considered viral by youtube
because all your traffic is internal,
but if you're someone like Jimmy Kimmel
and people love to share your crime
monologues across twitter,
then your video is going to hit the
training page because the views from
twitter account,
it is more valuable because it's coming
from across platforms.
This is why buzzfeed,
Gopro,
business insider,
big brands hit the trending page so
often because they have huge marketing
teams that spread their content across
all the platforms.
While independent youtube creators tend
to focus on youtube.
I want to talk for a moment why having
this system this way is a bad thing.
First,
youtube is not great because it houses
the highlights of TV.
Youtube is great because it isn't tv,
it isn't,
or at least wasn't dominated by big
corporations.
It was governed by a meritocracy of
independent creators.
In fact,
the whole reason for you dupes
popularity is thanks to these people.
So when Youtube makes one of the key
navigation options of their website
accessible to a small minority of
youtubers and to a large majority of
advertisers in TV influencers,
it seems like a bad move and a step away
from who they are at their core.
And in a weird way,
I'd prefer one of youtube own clickbait
monsters getting featured over going
back to the same tv culture ever cycled
over polished stuff that I could watch
on the TV.
I no longer pay for it because the
Internet is better.
How was Nebraska better than North
Dakota?
Hi,
is that Chuck's only funny in Nebraska?
My joke is not funny here.
Wow.
Oh my God,
I really don't believe this.
Second,
it isn't like we don't know where to
find these brands or TV shows.
If we wanted to watch them,
why shoved them down my throat?
I already know who Seth Meyer is.
Why not show someone who's blowing up on
youtube that I haven't heard of?
I mean,
in a way,
it's kind of ironic.
The trending tab was designed not to
over promote the already huge channels
and youtube,
but it ended up doing exactly that only
instead of promoting their own,
they're over promoting the very media
structures that they replaced a decade
ago.
And before you say,
okay,
but what about creator on the rise?
And that is a start,
but consider this.
There are 2 million people eligible to
be a creator on the rise,
which means that every day,
if you were dealt a hand of cards,
you draw a royal flush three times
before you got featured on the creator
on the rise page.
It's a gesture that looks good,
but it's pretty meaningless now given
you tube's incredible track record of
listening to creators,
I don't think this is going to change
anytime soon.
So it might be worth saying,
if you're a utuber and you ever want a
shot at hitting the TV guide of Youtube,
you might want to focus on diversifying
where your views come from because being
successful on youtube isn't enough.
You've got to have a large audience off
youtube,
which is a lot easier to do when your
main product isn't youtube.
So in the spirit of that,
if you like this video,
you can help my channel by liking my
twitter page and my facebook page linked
in the description below and retweet and
share this video.
If enough people watch and share this
video from other social media sites,
who knows,
we might just end up on the training
page,
but probably not.
I need my CNN sponsorship to come in
first.